[Musique]
et on va présenter l'ensemble des
résultats sportifs du week-end avec vous
nicolas dandrimont soir mozart et
gorille et vous oui vous nous présenter
ce qu'il s'est passé sportivement sur le
territoire que du football
pour ce week-end parce que les seuls
clubs à avoir repris les championnats à
l'aube du mois de septembre est passé
les clubs de football et on commence
avec ses images de nationale 2 pour le
compte de la 5e journée le fc mantois
affronter fleuri les yvelinoises se sont
inclinés sur leur terrain on vient de
voir une faute commise par les mantois
dans la surface de réparation donc un
penalty et puis on voit les mantois la
défense débordé par là les attaques des
essonniens
le score final 3-0 et de leur côté dans
la même poule poissy est allé chercher
un match nul sur le terrain du fc
lorient 2 2 sur les cinq premières
rencontres les pisciacais contre une
victoire deux nuls et deux défaites au
classement aucun illinois dans la
première partie du tableau on voit un
championnat dominé par chartres il faut
aller dans la seconde partie du tableau
pour voir poissy qui pointe à la 11e
place alors que les mantois occupe la
dernière place du classement avec cinq
défaites en cinq matches pour la
nationale 2 vous avez aussi des des
résultats de nationale 3 nous propose
est effectivement grégory début de
saison au royal pour versailles ils ont
remporté ce week-end le derby vinoy face
aux mureaux le score 3 0
au classement les versailles et occupe
la première place alors écoutez bien
quatre matches quatre victoires aucun
but encaissé mais ils ont fait trembler
les filets dix fois depuis le début de
la saison un bilan très positif on leur
souhaite de continuer on termine avec la
cette fois ci les divisions régionales
régionales de avec trappe et rap a
concédé sa deuxième défaite de la saison
en s'inclinant sur le terrain de poissy
2 mais soyons indulgents c'est seulement
leur deuxième match de la saison
au classement ils pointent à la dernière
place derrière champigny sur marne mais
seulement à cause du goal avérage
puisqu'ils ont tous les deux aucun point
et prochain rendez vous pour les 17
clubs il vit noah c'est le week-end
prochain avec le 3e tour de la coupe de
et deuxième match de la saison précise
aussi que tu rappes monte de division
effectivement donc se retrouve dans un
nouveau championnat avec des équipes
peut être un peu plus un peu plus forme
voilà on vous retrouve nicolas merci
pour pour ce point on vous retrouve dans
le 7-8 sport dans quelques instants et
vous allez nous parler notamment d'une
expédition en bolivie dans le désert
bolivien autrement une aventure dans des
conditions extrêmes à la fois physique
et et climatiques dans le dessert le
désert pardon de sel bolivien